hey y'all do you love middle ground
i know i do did you know that every
purchase made at the jubilee shop helps
fund this show if you're looking for
ways to support jubilee and watch more
episodes of middle ground make sure you
check out our merch at
shop.jubileemedia.com
honestly every one of your purchases
goes such a long way and we're so
grateful for you now enjoy this episode
if you truly believe that trans women
have a an advantage even with hormones
then that means you truly believe that
trans men have a disadvantage even with
hormones so the argument you hear most
of the time is against trans women so
does that mean that you're okay with
trans men having that disadvantage
hi my name is howard i've been a swimmer
for 13 years and currently i'm on the
ucla triathlon team my name's jing and
i've been swimming for 11 years hi i'm
lexi i've been playing indoor volleyball
for seven years i've been playing beach
volleyball for three years
my name is afton i play women's flat
track roller derby and i've been playing
since the end of 2018. my name is mac
bags i'm a wrestler i've been in combat
sports for eight years my name is sydney
i played tennis growing up for 13 years
and now i am a fitness coach
trans athletes have an unfair advantage
step forward if you agree
when you first think about like
transgender athletes i guess the first
thing you think about is well
biologically transition usually happens
after puberty right so
if this biologically
male athlete goes through puberty
he gets like better bone structure he
has all these skills that he enhances um
at least muscle that he puts on and then
he transitions
um yes your testosterone levels go down
but you're always just gonna have that
like things that you've gone through
like doing puberty that you have after
you've transitioned so i feel like
there's always gonna be that advantage i
think it's dependent on the gender that
they are transitioning to for example
trans women do have somewhat of an
advantage biological men are naturally
born with higher bone density and larger
lung capacity and a larger heart and
that's not something that can
necessarily be changed with hormones of
course this isn't the same for
trans uh
men athletes for me it's just on average
guys are typically a little bit stronger
a little bit larger a little bit taller
so depending on the sport especially
it can give them a large advantage when
you're looking at something like that
when it's something like swimming having
that ability to be a little bit larger
larger lung capacity will overall affect
that
can i have the disagreeable step forward
among
cisgender men and cisgender women there
are
naturally
differences in their anatomy in their
hormonal levels in their
height bone structure all that stuff
like any cisgender woman compared to
another might have a different body type
some women are naturally very strong
if you take
the advantage which i think
in most cases is the hormones
and if you compare the blood work and
you're just looking at that if they're
on the same level in my opinion there
just isn't an advantage because when you
grow up playing sports some people are
good at sports some people aren't the
problem i see with this argument is that
there's a large group of people that no
matter
what i do in a sport will always
automatically assume that i have an
advantage but they're not taking into
account hours that i put into practice
hours that i put into weight lifting to
become a better athlete roller derby is
probably
90 plus percent cis women i get my ass
handed to me
yes i i am tall and i can i can see that
that can be an advantage in some sports
but it doesn't necessarily
guarantee that i have an advantage oh
yeah what we usually hear in the like
news and like politics and stuff is
about trans women just because
they're in so much prominence because
they're
they are winning like i can't remember
what her name is right now but she was a
power lifter she is a power lifter i
think she went to tokyo olympics and
she's transgender
and um they're winning by like a large
amount like of weight if you truly
believe that trans women have a an
advantage even with hormones
then that means you truly believe that
trans men have a disadvantage even with
hormones so the argument that you hear
most of the time is against trans women
so does that mean that you're okay with
trans men having that disadvantage when
i was like going through high school
um
i
wrestled against females i had to
suppress both my hormones in my body and
i was still able to beat the men too
with my leg levels low like and i cut 15
pounds a week like that shouldn't that
that was crazy
but like that's what i'm saying like the
body is like a shell
and what we do every single day in the
practices and
the
like life lessons that we get like
living
40 years on this earth you know we just
try to live life the best we can yeah
trans athletes should have a separate
category in certain sports
i don't want to say that they should be
in a completely different category just
because
socially and legally yes they are
that gender that they transition to and
putting them in another category just
seems
from hindsight seems wrong but as an
athlete like in the sporting world it
just does seem a little bit unfair
if you classify them
under the same group i guess yeah i
think that there definitely are some
sports where your physical ability makes
a much larger impact on the sport itself
wrestling would be one of them swimming
track something like that but if you
look at nascar as a sport
i believe that anyone can then go and do
that sort of sport because that's more
of a technique if you look at
other sports like
golf it all requires a lot of technique
and a lot of strength plus video games
is now starting to make a massive rise
so all of those could definitely have
both genders in it with no problem for
swimming especially if i were to decide
that i would like to transition and then
start all of the hormone therapy for
multiple for a year or so then obviously
i would probably lose some muscle mass
and i would slow down in my swimming but
i don't know if that slow down would
necessarily be enough to make it fair
for the cis females
that i'd be competing up against
the danger of it is that you're possibly
outing somebody
in america alone there's several places
that it's still extremely dangerous to
be an open transgender person to say
that you can't
perform unless
you're in this group there there's just
a lot of safety reasons for that
individual that is not good second thing
where does the line draw you're saying
swimming
and you had mentioned earlier that like
height was an advantage did i go through
puberty as a male
yes
but in order to say that i have an
advantage because i was born with
testosterone is the equivalent of saying
that oh i went to this gym one time and
i lifted and i had a protein shake so i
should never have to take a protein
shake again because it's in my body and
the medicine i'm taking stops that
testosterone i don't have that anymore
like my entire body my entire mind my
entire way of thinking is different
because of the medicine i'm on are we
gonna start making categories for cis
athletes okay you're in a category if
you're five nine and above
uh five seven to five nine you know five
five five seven weights like all those
things it's like exactly where is the
line i mean they do have weight category
well yeah for certain sports of course
but i mean i think just generally
every person is different like you're
saying like the cis women that were
getting cut because they're naturally
you know more athletic to some standard
that says like or even the varying
levels of testosterone exactly you're in
this box so now you're in this league
yeah
i wasn't by any chance trying to
discriminate against them and try and
put them in their own category in that
way it was more just by a performance
standpoint we already do separate
everyone into their own different levels
you don't have olympic athletes coming
and competing at stakeholders club
levels doesn't that defeat the purpose
of trying to become a better athlete
then
if they're trying to work up to a goal
i'm not entirely sure so if you're good
enough you're going to be singled out
and have to go
there is there's no proof of any trans
athlete that is number one in any
category right now
yeah that's because i think they're
being held back so much by just like the
media and everything that you don't get
to see their chance to shine in that
sense what would you guys say to like
transgender people who transitioned
before puberty
and that insists i think i would take a
step back and kind of look at it more of
at like my own argument like it was a
scientific scientifically based on like
puberty and stuff so i would like
consider like it that would be different
but
my mindset just coming into this i mean
i think that most people go through
transitioning like after puberty or it's
like encouraged to yeah yeah for me it's
more if they end up just fitting the
category regardless if they do it before
puberty or after puberty if they have
the right amount of testosterone they
did the
all the right testing all beforehand
then why not then you don't even need to
separate them they might as well just
compete as a trans athlete
hormone testing is fair
like the olympics test college level
tests
i know like in texas at my high school
level the uil organization they tested
um
and you know it's to keep everybody safe
and
i think it's okay to test for hormone
levels and if that's the ultimate like
you know
conversation here is that we're looking
in people for hormone levels as a
competition
then
why separate men and women why are we
talking about men and women we should
talk we just strictly talk about hormone
levels
so there is varying levels of
testosterone blockers that you can be on
i chose to be on one of the higher ones
but i can guarantee you that someone
like me is going to get less of a chance
to be cut than a cis female because my
hormones will stay the same whereas a
cyst is going to be
all over the place depending on
all sorts of variables yeah i personally
think that the hormone testing is
really important and just coming from
like a fitness perspective like fitness
bodybuilding like that sort of athletic
athletics
for me
i take a lot of pride in the fact that
my testosterone levels are within the
normal range of a cisgender male
obviously performance enhancers right
steroids extra testosterone all those
things are thrown around among cisgender
men in the fitness world to you know
enhance our performance get bigger all
that sort of thing and for me being able
to say like no
i am within the normal range of a
cisgender man the muscle i'm putting on
i'm naturally putting on i don't have an
advantage over anybody else that's in
that normal range so i think
for me like it's just really important
because i'm like proud of that and i
think if you just assume that a trans
person has an advantage because they're
taking testosterone it's kind of like
well what about cis men that take
testosterone to get bigger and that sort
of thing so
testing for hormones is fine the issue
is what you're gonna do with that
because
as i said earlier it's really hard to
put someone in a box because there's
always averages here and there for male
and female but especially when you start
making your way up in the competition
pool
those norms go out the window and it
then gets even more difficult to write
legislation
on what a male can compete in and what a
female can compete in for if their
hormone levels are outside of this said
box
i'm fine as a trans athlete being tested
if i need to prove to the world that
like i'm the better athlete at the end
of the day
go ahead and take my medical information
i don't care
like i'm just trying to live my truth
that's all i'm trying to do a cis female
that's competing in
a high level of track might have a
normal male testosterone so now are you
going to kick them out because now their
testosterone levels are too high and
that's where legislation can get really
difficult to write
i am treated fairly by my fellow
athletes
i
joined roller derby only like four
months after i decided to transition and
get onto hormones everyone from the
beginning was very accepting roller
derby is almost almost too accepting
from my experience because i forgot how
bad the real world can be sometimes not
everyone is going to be
but my personal experience has been very
positive growing up i in my club i
trained with my brother and we were like
kind of in the distance group so it was
mostly guys there and they never really
saw me as like like she's a girl you
know they just saw me as like another
competitor it was always just fun like
racing and like i just yeah it just made
me
grow up love being
in the sporting world and being
competitive with everyone so yeah i
definitely get a lot of hate like online
but i've never personally gotten any
like issues like everyone that's in the
gym is just trying to get better for the
most part obviously that kind of
communal idea is really like helpful
as far as me not getting so much hate
lonely times
when in high school when i came out like
prominently
everybody knew that was trans and there
was a coach that exploited me
uh in a lawsuit
to try to ban me in high school yeah um
sorry wow i was on hormone blockers and
it was suppressing my estrogen and
testosterone and
even though everybody knew who i was
when it came to like after junior high
when he did that it was so aggressive
parents would scream from the stands
that they
wanted to hurt me as being a trans man
and just in my life in general my family
doesn't come from much
and we work very hard and i'm like the
first generation to try to become
something
so
i mean
[Music]
should be gender neutral
your body's a vessel it shouldn't matter
whether you're male or female because i
feel like the sport like sports in
general is growing
especially there's this like little girl
in wrestling she wrestled in the junior
division in wrestling and nationals in
the 106 pound division and she kicked
all the guys asses
i was like go for you
um so i feel like as the sport's growing
as we're evolving as a society and we're
being very progressive
that
it should get to the point if we're
talking about gender-neutral bathrooms
why can't we talk about gender-neutral
sports sure i actually rode and um
showed equestrian for 10 years and i was
like one of two
men at the time and then there are other
roller derby leagues that are co-ed and
they work
fine
like women are going up against men and
they're bashing each other and they're
like going at it there's a lot of things
and i feel like sports are one of these
things where it's like it has to be this
or it has to be that the same as gender
it has to be this or it has to be that
and it's not
[Music]
for me the issue that i would start
seeing with this is when
we start looking at scholarships and for
college level if you start combining the
sports by gender then
scholarships are always given to the top
athletes
what happens to the females that now
need that scholarship necessarily to go
to college but now you've just all
thrown them into one category it all of
a sudden
breaks that whole opportunity for them
to maybe even go to college because now
they've been training to be able to
provide for themselves in college
and now since it's all one level playing
field maybe they can beat the males but
on average they probably won't be able
to especially depending on the sport so
trans athletes aren't even getting
scholarships either
i won i've been i'm a two-time state
champion high school didn't get a
scholarship
i just now been able to get my
scholarship three years into being on a
male team yeah but we were talking like
hypothetically in the perfect world if
sports was gendered yeah and that's why
i'm saying like it's all hypothetical
yeah everything's hypothetical in a
sense because we don't have enough
analytical data i feel as though making
all sports gender
neutral in that way there is still some
biological uh
benefits to being
born a man versus being born a female
i just can't
get over the fact that there are going
to be all these very obvious
differences not advantages but just
differences in if we had gender neutral
sports it's not going to be a co-ed team
versus an all-male team it's going to be
a co-ed team versus a co-ed team so it
was i i feel like there would still be
strategy that
you would have to be played into it i'm
thinking more like individually yeah
individual and i can see like
where you're coming from that and i you
mentioned wrestling earlier
just the whole combat sport community in
general does have a long way to go
definitely like not completely
supportive of trans athletes but in a
sense of like when i've noticed and just
like studying of how like female
athletes are and male athletes are the
best like mma
female athletes cis
have male training partners
and most of the time like they're
kicking their ass unless like they're
training
for or unless they have somebody that's
better than them to push them and then
that's just making them a better athlete
in my opinion like kids are extremely
accepting it's i have two
gorgeous kids
and um it's so cool to have them play on
a playground and explain to their new
friends who i am and like watch them do
that and their kids like their friends
will be like okay
you know but you talk to a an adult and
they're like
uh you know because you have this
instilled like what you were saying this
instilled education from the time you
were born
that has basically said that no this is
wrong you have to have this group you
have to have this group you have to have
this group like i i do talk about it a
lot with people but i have to understand
that it's not my responsibility
to educate everyone like i have to be
able to cross that line where it's like
mentally i can't do it anymore like i
need to step back for a little bit um
but like you said like it ask questions
like if you're genuine as long as i know
it's not um
malicious yeah ask a question don't
don't freaking ask me about my genitals
like yeah that's none of your freaking
be respectful
i just want to know like have you guys
ever
had like you were talking about your
scholarship do you guys feel like you
have less opportunity in the sense of
like competitions and like scholarships
just because you guys are attributes
when kovitz started roller derby since
then has not gotten back together so i
lost my sport um which was something
that was like really kept my brain
in focus and like centered me so i got
into power lifting i lift because i'd
enjoy it but i don't even try and and
compete just because
people are gonna like i don't want the
backlash wrong yeah i'm sorry yeah it's
it's gotten for me to that point a
little bit a couple of years ago it was
like all too much and it took to my
coach has was
fortunate and supported me through like
my academic journey and he was like if
you can't if you feel like you can't do
this anymore like as long as you got
good grades like and you know when we're
being asked like in high school like
when we're like going to be competing on
a high level you know the first thing
that comes out of a recruiter or a
recruiter's mouth is what are your
grades not how good you are i mean i
think i just learned a lot like uh i
loved hearing all of your y'all stories
and i feel sad that you guys like feel
oppressed sometimes and don't even try
you know i hope this educates people
my job right there
[Music]
you